[Music]
okay let's talk about the media no
because because you can talk about we
can talk ourselves into a Trump style
yes digit spinner and not going to get
us anywhere so the media he drove this
truck through it I do think it's great I
think it's helped voices like yours like
what we're doing here like many other
people who are not promising all the
answers but at least promising
discussions and and some some lines of
thought that maybe weren't getting out
there in the mainstream do you think
that there is a risk in that too that we
are just going to filter ourselves into
oblivion to the point where instead of
having three news channels we're now
going to have a gajillion of them and
we're all going to hate each other for a
zillion new reasons that we didn't even
realize it definitely there's a definite
moral hazard here I mean free you know
as as as these lawyers and our press
keep saying a free press is important to
a free society and you do want I mean
another thing that's working well under
Trump is that everybody that the press
is attacking the people in power and
said what they did during the Obama
administration
where they kept their hands over their
eyes and said oh look and he
scandal-free right I would argue there's
a little bit of an overcorrection
happening over correction no question
about but that's because they're so
corrupt I mean that's why so I do
believe in a I can't remember the word
but I press that basically stands up to
power I do believe in a free press we
don't have a free press we have a press
that has been corrupted beyond its
purposes and that doesn't mean they're
no good reporters that means that a good
reporter in the New York Times is
basically doing the wrong thing because
he's giving credence and he's giving
credence and credibility to a sophomoric
left-wing college magazine and with
these can you give an example of that
cuz that's the type of it so I attack
CNN all the time I've seen some bad
stuff lately out of the New York Times
yeah where the headline leads you one
way and then when you read it it really
isn't what it said they've been doing a
lot of Corrections lately which usually
no one reads the correction well you
never see any of that but when I when I
do attack the New York Times people give
me more [ __ ] like CNN it's like
everyone's in on the joke yes
but new york times it's a little bit
different so when you describe it as a
South Lauren
will yellow that oh there I mean if you
read their op-ed page which I now call
knucklehead row you know every their
op-ed page it really is like a bunch of
eight-year-old girls in a room where a
mouse has gotten a listen so they're all
screaming and yeah I have already run
around his stare and and that's really
unfair to eight-year-old girl if you
read I mean just yesterday they ran a
story Donald Trump jr. met with a
Russian lawyer and all this who cares I
mean who cares Donald Trump jr. met with
a Russian border to get infant because
he thought she had information on the
opposition and everything you know
faints and who can't I saw celebrities
well-known people saying this is it this
is the collusion we've been looking for
it's a penetrator whole story it's
called opposition research everyone does
that ever you think Hillary didn't meet
with people to see if they had
information on Trump and only in an
organization where no one is sitting
next to you who says dude that's not a
story that's a 30 page 30 story only in
a place where everybody thinks we found
the smoking gun can you make a fool of
yourself like that yeah you know in
other words you want somebody to say to
you you know like I I know you're a
conservative but there is something to
not letting people starve to death in
the streets
oh yeah it's amount of okay you fellas
like it and the opposite is true you
know yeah I know you're a left winger
but everybody does Oppo research and you
know the fact that she was from Russia
makes doesn't mean this thing you know
it by the way as far as I know he didn't
buy anything from everywhere it was a
ruse to get him to talk about this
ruling you know that limits the way they
can use banks and all this stuff hey you
know we've been listening to this stupid
story for six months this Russian story
it is not a story I mean it's just not
and even even the Russian meddling with
the election which I believe happened is
kind of like finding a spy you know we
go oh my goodness there's a spy who
would ever spy i mcai know but like you
know can we bring our spies back for a
couple yeah that's what this is like we
do it to them and all this and they do a
thought so the New York Times has become
and it's dishonest it they use good
reporters and good reporting to tell a
dishonest story and the fact that they
think that they even can conceive
the idea that they're not a leftist rag
shows you how far gone they are I mean
that they cannot you know take it just
any day pick up the Wall Street Journal
and pick up the New York Times and The
Wall Street Journal you're talking to an
adult
the New York Times you're talking to a
child well is it it's interesting that
you made a point of saying the op-ed
pages too because obviously you expect
opinion either way right so that's a
separate than the editorial said buddy
but they're up in Page the reaction to
some of the things that they're doing
have gone insane so they brought Brad
Stevens from The Wall Street Journal he
writes that one piece basically just
about skepticism didn't even really say
he doesn't believe in climate change
like I think he may have even said the
opposite yeah but then they were
immediately people demanding he be fired
and all of this craziness just for
having an alternate opinion on their
op-ed page but the one that I thought
was more interesting do you see the one
a couple weeks ago about Brett Weinstein
from Evergreen State and it was all
about campus free speech but basically
the thrust of it at the end was we as
liberal as better start caring about
this because it's coming for us right
but I thought what an odd admission you
you're now admitting that you didn't
care about free speech because it was
comment about coming against the other
people right now it's finally turning on
a guy who's left left left super
progressive so now we better start
caring like there was a strange
admission like it was refreshing I
suppose it is but I mean I think the New
York Times has just gone so far down
this hole that an article like that
stands out you know when you read an
article like that in a touch but like
wow even in the New York Times then now
for free speech you know that's that's
not good you know like the New York
Times would be for free speech every day
for everyone every day the other work
time should have conservatives on on the
desks where the news decisions are being
made you know the The Wall Street
Journal is is anti-trump in its news
pages and sometimes unfairly I think but
not crazily you know they have people
obviously correcting their opinions it
you know becomes a level that comes a
time when the level of corruption gets
so bad that audacity becomes a kind of a
brag so you see this in governments all
the time you see it in Illinois places
like Chicago and things like this where
remember the the boss tweed and the
little tin box put the money in a little
tin box
audacious corruption yeah is this is
these comes from a sense that we are so
corrupt that no one can touch us okay
when you put George Stephanopoulos a
Clinton hack at the top of your news
team he is your news guy that's a sign
that you have become corrupt yeah it's
not that he died baby sea-doos yeah
that's a B she has not not that he's not
a nice man or whatever he is he's a guy
once said to Hillary I love you Hillary
he can have a role in your news
department but he should not be running
in your news department the guy at CBS
who just looks like Ted Baxter to me you
know the remember from the viruses in
Scott Pelley yeah mate who made
decisions so biased during the Obama
administration that his only reporters
didn't want their stories going on his
air because they didn't want to do what
I was talking about with serve a biased
report this corruption has become so
manifest and so absurd that to see it
taken down is a beautiful thing but
you're right we need to replace it with
something of value we need to replace it
with something that works so is that why
they're hitting back so hard so the CNN
thing that happened last week with this
threat to Docs
this person who did under typically
legal thing it is legal to make memes by
the way he didn't make it for Trump Oh
however it got to Trump and it sounds
like it was actually a slightly altered
version like we don't know how it is but
there are millions of people making
memes on the Internet as we sit here
right the second it wasn't just that
they were threatening to Doc's this guy
for doing something legal
it was the line after that where they
said he's agreed not to do this
offensive blah blah again Isis they're
the church or his parents or something
so it to me that was that was the
scarier thing not the threat of the docs
which of course is wrong but the threat
that they were tacitly saying or
implicitly saying to everybody else
we're watching you too and we're going
to come for all of you know and then the
internet turned on them in a beautiful
fashion right and but it was only the
follow-up and the completion of the
logic that went after Joe the Plumber
and of course the rightness handled that
by elevating Joe the Plumber to some
kind of commentator because he had been
attacked but remember Joe the Plumber
went out and asked a question of a
political candidate and they went after
the guy asked the question yeah you know
I mean this is what
how corrupt they've become and they are
thuggish that it and this is all of them
this is I mean I'm talking about the
networks I'm talking about the times I'm
talking about wopo and I'm talking about
CNN which is and in some ways the least
of them because it's just a small
operation that would vanish like that if
people cut their cable towards you right
right baby what's that thing they say
that if they would get CNN at a airports
it would lose light it would lose all of
this all of its of viewers yeah you know
it's all of these guys and and they hate
hasn't even occurred to one of them not
one of them has said well you know Trump
is being a jerk and Trump is not it's
not fair what he does it's really wrong
when he attacks our reporter in terms of
her face or whatever you know like but
he has a point you know we need to
reform our industry there's a reason
that the people believe Donald Trump
more than they believe us as a reason
that people hate us so much so it really
is that they've just been drunk on power
got these left
whatever it is thirty years they've been
drunk on power for so long and now they
finally have someone throwing it in
their face and now the people the actual
people are rising up against them to
that and I thought you saw probably
Chris Cuomo who of course his brother is
the mayor or the governor he's or you're
one he's another was the Governor of New
York
he's an idiot he's like a Fredo from the
core yeah he really I mean I every time
you see the guy he's just another just
better yeah but he tweeted something
about you know these hateful needs and
should we release the information
because the guys tweeted some other vici
stuff and all that and they ended up
deleting it
but I retweeted him I said would you say
that a meme or a gif is worse than what
then Linda Sarsour calling for jihad now
we talked about it briefly before we
started but regardless of whether she
meant her own personal jihad but she's
talking about the white supremacists and
Islamophobes in the White House and
everyone knows if you're using that word
you're trying to like gin up a certain
something and might week got way more
retweets and everything than any of his
do he has a million followers and almost
no interaction which also tells you a
little something but I bring this up
because it's like of course he doesn't
respond because they think they're
beholden to nobody to where it's like
we're but we actually are beholden to
our audience you know when I was in the
newspaper mouths newspaperman a small
with a very powerful and somewhat
corrupt sheriff so I was like out of a
movie you know and I would I would
badger there and I remember saying to
what I had some sources in the
department and I remember saying to one
of them look we work for this we both
work for the people and he turned around
they said I work for the people you work
for a corporation and I thought my god
he's right man I'm not he said really
you know that's they don't understand
that they're just mouthpieces for big
corporations which love big government
because big government hurts the little
guy you know that's off they're just
standing up for these powerful
corporations in the name of all the
leftists you know by words and all this
stuff you know they really have lost any
real sense of themselves and it's just
it's it's pitiful to watch in some ways
but it is good to see it getting exposed
and what I would like to see on the
right I feel on the right we have a lot
of really good people like you and me D
and Ben and all these people expressing
opinions but we I don't consider myself
part of the right moving into
libertarians yeah I would say and I'm
still a liberal okay which is a fine
line between that and a libertarian but
yes I hate to even pause you there to
say that but I know a certain amount of
people start screaming but I consider my
I'm more than happy to talk to hell you
go but I say it all the time that I'm a
conservative because I'm a yeah it's all
just a diversion okay yeah and and I I
think that like I would like to see us
start to gather information and that's
expensive and you need people to back
you and you needed to somehow make it
profitable but we need to start sending
people to the hotspots because for me to
get the facts I have to go to the New
York Times and The Wall Street Journal
at CNN and all these places because they
hire reporters and it's opinions are
great and insights are great and there
is now because the press is so corrupt
there is an actual need for people like
us
to say they're telling you the facts
mean this but the fact actually might
mean this you know that is an actual
profession now it's a real profession
that needs to be done but I would like
to see the right go after have people in
Iraq have people in you know in the hot
spots of the world have people in
Washington DC the best news program on
television is
there's special rapport because they
gather news and because they're fair
even though he's you know even though
they tilt to the right
they're very fair about what they come
are you shocked by the breadth of it
just sort of the amount of activists
masquerading as journalists because
that's what I think they are truly these
people are not I mean I've seen just
some of the recent hit pieces on me yeah
and it's like no matter how much I plead
my case or defend myself or show them
evidence to the contrary about it you
know some Mother Jones calling me an
extremist to the right of Breitbart I
know ya and it's real doozy and it's
like you know they don't correct
anything they don't care they know their
job is safe and it's like forgetting all
that you're not a journalist like that's
why I tweet a good guy something to that
effect like I just want you to admit
you're not journalists right wait right
what you want even though I probably had
a decent case reliable right wait you
want but can you admit what you're doing
and it's like that sort of that lack of
self-awareness you know I've been I've
now been saying this to the right for
10-15 years about our loss of the
culture and that's what this is this is
the result of our loss of the
university's of our loss of TV stations
you know women's magazines every women's
magazine is left-wing every comedian on
television every late-night comedian
every single one is a left winger
not one not one woman and when and when
one of them made a joke was nice to
Donald Trump he was basically pilloried
you know he had to write really fast and
he found I was alone yeah I mean it's
hard to tell the difference they're all
exactly right everyone how do we how did
we let that happen and why don't we
respond and I always just I always say
to conservatives that telling them about
the culture is like trying to explain to
my wife when she buy something on sale
it still cost money and I always looks
at me and goes and says you know you're
a cute guy yeah I like you but I don't
know what you're talking about that's
the way conservatives look at me you
know they how did we get to the point
where we have people talking like a
hundred year old man going I don't go to
the movies anymore I just turn on Turner
cloudy and Doris Day is good number you
know I mean that that's insane and how
do we get to the point where we start
making stuff that educates people
to be right-wingers but simply to just
open their minds a little bit so I don't
know what your feelings are on Milo but
I suspect after hearing you say that you
must at least love much of the movement
behind one right with the secret agent
key that isn't that thing that you're
now saying we got we're winning the
culture war back I mean he talked about
that all the time right here you know
that is such a great question it really
is a great question because Milo gives
me Fitz I've only spoken to Milo once we
had a long conversation about video
games he was when he was on gamergate
yeah and and I like the men you know I
mean I got along with he has done some
stuff that's so vicious partly to my
friend ben shapiro which I resent
because he's my friend yeah and
anti-semitic and and he's given given
shelter to anti-semites which I always
feel the minute ice min I see
anti-semitism area in the coal mine you
know that's where like evil dwells
basically they usually go for the Jews
they go for the Jews first and like so
there's stuff that he's done that I just
think is great and I wish that he would
you know find himself in a somewhat
better place because there is such a
thing even though I believe everyone
should be allowed to speak there are
some things that are when spoken or
reprehensible you know oh thank you so I
get whether their consequences seriously
that's right you know and when I hear
him you know I don't know the June
remarks and the and the kind of their
kind of hateful allowing hatefulness to
be cute allowing it to be ironic saying
you know I prefer can say for instance I
heard him say when when our generation
is anti-semitic they're just being
ironical I think like yeah that's a
snake that's going to bite back you know
I don't I don't really buy into that and
and so I like what he's doing I don't
always like the way that he's doing it
or what he's doing it in service to but
certainly when he had what's called a
dangerous [ __ ] or yeah I laughed out
loud right but I want more of those guys
I mean it was Breitbart and I used to
have this conversation all the time you
know when I first met Breitbart he kind
of enlisted me into the LA right and he
did almost all of us you know I said to
him I want to tell you right up front
that I'm not going into this gay stuff
because this anti-gay stuff because I
think we're going to lose I said hey
we're going to lose which is no shame
but we're going to lose and be wrong and
that's our shaming that's really
shameful Breitbart said to me what I
want is more patriotic gay porn
sign me up brother to straight guy is
demanding motivation is how much you
people agree we're going to watch it but
what about it you know and and so I
think that you know I have this
conversation with people about Milo all
the time I see a good as he is doing
I see dangers in the way he's doing it
and I think you can be too ironical
about too much because there is moral
universe and you do not want to you
didn't want to blow yourself through it
yeah do you think that's kind of the
fasting bar game that you have to play
you're getting what you want what you've
wanted here and you as a guy that's been
through the Hollywood machine yeah so
you're you're getting the culture winds
that really if you had let's say he had
done you know been a little more careful
with his language not done some of the
unnecessary over-the-top stuff or
whatever that it might have it might
have shamed some of the the good part
that you want yeah maybe just wouldn't
have broke through today and that is
that's kind of what the trump the
trumpian bargain a federated is only a
guy as uncaring about the niceties would
have driven his truck into the media the
way he did and I think that does it come
with moral hazards yes do people have to
speak up about those moral hazards and
take the flak from the right when they
say you know oh you're a [ __ ] and you're
all these things yes we have to take
that flak but it has to be done because
I think we had reached a tipping point I
hate to use a cliched phrase like that
but I think we had reached a tipping
point where we were sounding very much
like a communist country like there was
things that you could say it made you
persona non grata that there were
opinions you could have that you know
the trap door like the James Bond
villain you ever thought of the trap
door I think we were in a dangerous
point and if we and political
correctness is a smothering toxic evil
device for making lines seem like a
virtue and if Donald Trump destroys
political correctness
people have done a great thing
I mean a great thing and the thick that
it has moral hazards come along with
that I think we shouldn't forget it you
know a good example of this is when they
shut down Shakespeare in the Park who
the other day now Shakespeare that was
reprehensible to assassinate the
president on stage I really think you
know as a Shakespeare fan I think that
it was a an awful awful thing to do but
they would have done the same thing if
it was Obama right yeah but to shut them
down and to have my friends you know
writing that this was a good thing you
know that that's a mistake yeah I
completely agree because now what you're
saying it's okay to fight to say well
we've got to be as tough as the left but
to say we've got to be as tough as the
left for things that the left would
approve of like shutting down free
speech that doesn't make any sense to me
yeah and that's why you both and that's
why again the sides the sides are just
becoming yeah meaningless and nine-time
I think that that's a really good
observation because I do think that I
and I had this is part of a problem I
have with the right right now is I keep
saying to them you know you're right
they're disturbed because the
conservative movement has essentially
collapsed and then when Trump swept all
those guys off the stage the way he did
in the primaries the conservative
movement that was done for and my
response to that is fix it you know put
it back together differently you know
get it's a new world they can do
conservative conservatism you don't have
to get rid of your principles you don't
be able to your big principles but you
might have to get rid of some of the
ways those principles express themselves
in the world yeah so is that just that's
just real politic right I mean it seems
to me here is you're just viewing the
world as it is Matt as you wanted to be
so if you if you had a guy like like
Bill Kristol where it's like he wants
that conservative thing to exist again
yes I don't think you can make that
happen or you certainly can't it's going
to go through several other iterations
before it was ever to get back to
something like that
yeah no I'm interested in guys like
Henry Olson who are basically saying
pointing out that Reagan was kind of an
FDR Democrat more than anything else and
he invented kind of modern conservatism
I'm interested in guys who say look this
is the field of play and this is where
we want to get see this is this is the
thing that I know that I've noticed a
lot of commentators don't I know where I
want to get I want to get to more
freedom
I have more freedom now six months after
the election of Donald Trump seven
months after the election of Donal Trump
than I did eight months ago no question
in my mind the fact that the EPA can't
now rule my sink a waterway and declare
that they can now tell me whether I can
shave or not you know I think that that
makes me more free I think that being
said Trump may not be great on him in a
domain right because he might want this
wall to cut through that you know who
knows where all that now but I assure
you he would have no problem using
eminent domain to make a cut through no
no I was shy about it ya know they're
all these dangers involved and so I just
want to see is the ball moving in the
freedom direction all the time and right
now it is and you know I definitely see
moral hazards I definitely look at a guy
Milo I mean he's in such a good example
because I look at him and there are
things that he does that I make me laugh
out loud and I just think it's wonderful
he's here and then suddenly he'll say
something and I think except wait don't
you don't want to give credence to
hatred and evil you know I mean if evil
evil is bigger than irony I know we'll
eat iron ax you know and so you want to
be careful about that and I feel that
that could have been the ending but I'm
going to ask you one other thing which
is do you fear perhaps that these forces
which have grown so fat and we're so
drunk on their own power and all that
now that it's starting to crumble do you
fear that they will hit back on people
like you and people like me and whoever
in a way that we may don't we may not
understand yet in other words that that
bad thing that they did with the hon
[ __ ] solo and the gif where the meme
was a warning shot only of the way that
they're going to try to treat the people
who go against them well I think we've
seen it with these leaks from the
intelligence community about Donald
Trump did this and they turned out some
of those weeks turned out not to be true
but the press was perfectly happy to say
sources within the intelligence
community former officials and you think
well what does a former official know
didn't matter they were putting a front
page that was the first page in the New
York Times The Washington Post they were
that was the deep State striking back
there's no question about it they're
going to continue to fight this is a
genuine battle this is a genuine battle
for you know I hate to say it but it's a
battle for the future I mean I think
that this glue
world which has many good things in it I
think of free trade and global
communication all this also allowed a
small group of people to make decisions
unelected people to make decisions for
for people who had no way to redress
their grievances and I think that that
can't be you know if we're going to
become a global world then I want
America to take it over basically I'm an
imperialist in that regard if we if the
world's global fine but everybody's
living under the Constitution that's the
way it's going to be if not if
everybody's not living under the
Constitution Saudi Arabia doesn't want
to live under the Constitution then I
want Saudi Arabia to stay in Saudi
Arabia and I want Saudi Arabians to stay
in Saudi Arabia unless they want to come
over here to live under the Constitution
so those are the choices right that's an
interesting way to frame and we are
there's a global world run by the
Constitution or America first why I drew
a anonymous source and Capitol Hill I'm
telling you right now that this was
excellent interview as over to talk to
you but we can continue the conversation
oh I get my anonymous source I got a
hose from Gloria Borgia doing quoting
this anonymous like I'm talking to the
janitor like who a source on Capitol if
anybody well that's what I want people
understand if anybody it's all made up
it's for the pleasure done so as always
and for more on Andrew check him out on
the Andrew Clavin show brilliant name by
the way where they say I think no is
amazing we work for ages on it yeah the
Andrew Clavin show it's right here on
the YouTube
[Music]
you